in a world sometimes divided 2017
brought together some of our favorite
artists and let's be real we needed them
here's a look back at nine of the year's
biggest collaborations Kendrick Lamar
recruited Rihanna for this fire track
off damn proven what's life without
loyalty if you could take it
RiRi was a busy bad gal in 2017 though
because she was also featured on dj
khaled wild thoughts when I was ner DS
lemon leaves also double-dip this year
catapulted Luis FONSI and daddy Yankees
Esposito to the top of the Billboard Hot
100 song earned a Grammy nomination for
record of the year but wasn't the only
bilingual crossover hit right
Beyonce surprised everyone when she
popped up in the me gente remix with J
Balvin and Willie William weeks later
she teamed up with Ed Sheeran for
perfect duet earning the singer her
first number-one song since single
ladies now I know
[Applause]
[Music]
now the year's best electronic labs came
courtesy of kygo and Selena Gomez
Zed and Alicia Cora and Calvin Harris
featuring Frank Ocean and me goes do you
style
[Music]
there were so many jams we couldn't even
try to list them all here but hit us in
the comment section with some of your
favorite music claps here's to hope in
2018 is just as harmonious
[Music]